et maintenant comme villa on m'appelle
sinon
[Applaudissements]
thomas pianiste regardant ce pas cool
c'est pas cool pour thème la désole
c'est stupide on m'appelle simple et
enfin franchement c'est pas vous qui
choisissez musique soit moi non c'est
fun sinon c'est le producteur de
l'émission j'irai navarette parkway puis
j'ai pas du tout simple et assez
ridicules
pense à vue
[Rires]
bonne année thierry bonne année à toi
des bonnes années
[Applaudissements]
par contre thierry si je peux me
permettre c'est tromper parce que le
nouvel an chinois c'est le 7 février
vous ne vous l'avais invité trop tôt
bouna limoux nai binh c'est un copain on
partage la même scène trois semaines on
joue dans la cave d'un restaurant bon
sauf que boone il à la plonge mais
non mais bouderont d'antan surnom c'est
chinois marrant c'est un peu raciste moi
je cautionne pas comme si on disait je
pars à rachida dati c'est l'arabe
ambitieuse franchement ça se fait pas
non mais c'est vrai
mais à chinois marrant c'est génial
comme concept le problème c'est qu'un
chinois qui sourit on sait jamais si
c'est parce qu'il est content ou qui
parce qu'il prépare un sale con non mais
c'est pas fait le stagiaire d'ici
trois mois tu peux me payer moins cher
non il faut faire attention à ce qu'on
dit parce que le problème c'est que ce
qui est chiant france et qu'un chinois
qui fait des blagues sur les chinois
c'est normal un blanc qui fait des
blagues sur les chinois c'est un raciste
alors qu'un chinois qui fait des blagues
aux blancs ça s'appelle un restaurateur
[Applaudissements]
rachida dati bonsoir aïe oh non non non
vous inquiétez pas rachida tout va bien
se passer je les aime beaucoup vraiment
rachida c'est la première à montrer
qu'on pourrait être une femme en
politique et avoir du style donc ses
enseignants juste pour régir une petite
polémique parce que sur internet il ya
des gens qui ont dit que qu'il pensait
que vous aviez fait de la chirurgie
esthétique moi je pense pas que vous en
avez besoin non mais vraiment non mais
moi ça me fait marrer la chirurgie
esthétique parce que on veut on veut que
ça se voit mais on veut pas que ça se
sache ouais un peu comme quand votre
front national en fait c'est
alors
[Applaudissements]
azul à vous êtes députée européenne il
ya des avantages et des inconvénients 1
le seul avantage que je vois c'est que
les députés français tous les mercredis
sont les rémissions sur france 3 ça veut
dire que on voit ceux qui bossent tous
ceux qu'ils ont les couilles alors qu'à
strasbourg personne ne sait ce qui se
passe c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai
j'ai vu un reportage à la télé il ya des
députés ils sont tellement vicieux ils
vont pointer à 7h du matin et après ce
bar et il saute dans le premier tgv moi
je trouve ça dégueulasse mais pour 10000
euros par mois moi aussi je fais des
allers retours à strasbourg enfin
il ya des erreurs à strasbourg vous ne
pouvez pas signé partir parce que sinon
vous n'êtes pas payé vous avez un quota
d'heures a raté à amiens et et on gagne
pas dix mille euros par mois écouter sur
internet ces peluches et y compris les
séances
stéphane plaza va vous êtes animateur
télé comédie agents immobiliers alors
j'ai appris que vous aviez vécu jusqu'à
l'âge de 30 ans avec votre maman l'agent
immobilier qui vit chez ses parents
jusqu'à l'âge de 30 ans j'avais bien
dire quand même les cordonniers sont les
plus mal chaussés c'est vrai chez les
juifs séfarades ses taux mais sinon
c'est arpentant quand même mesdames et
messieurs je suis ici pour vous poser
les questions trop con que thierry
ardisson n'a pas voulu vous posez
rachida dati d'alors dans la politique
on dit que vous n'aimez pas vous faire
marcher sur les pieds ce à cause de vos
chaussures de luxe ou pas
on dit rachida que pour ne rien rater de
ce qui se passe dans les halls du 7e
arrondissement chaque mois vous recevez
les concierges à la mairie du 7ème du
brouhaha et mis longtemps à prendre le
portugais ou pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
good i'm in blood vous êtes chinois et
vous fait des blagues c'est parce que
vous étiez trop nul en chambre pour le
karaoke
stéphane plaza à
maylis itation stéphane j'ai lu que vous
aviez trouvé votre votre moitié vous
pouvez nous la dcri a fait combien de
mètres carrés loi carrese
poutres apparentes ou pas non il n'y a
pas de coups apparentes sait si on va
dans l'arène je ne vais pas tout dans le
marais
unis j'y vais excellent boiron petit
c'est tout
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu